sans rejeter l'extension de la déchéance
de nationalité est ce qu'on peut
imaginer que le sénat va trouver un
compromis sur les autres dispositions
clés de ce texte c'est quand même un
revers un revers on qu'on savait que le
passage de cet article serait difficile
alors même que la commission des lois
avait apporté des avancées de mon point
de vue singulière est extrêmement
importante c'est la raison pour laquelle
je reste peut être confiant sur la
navette parlementaire qui va s'ouvrir
maintenant sur les autres dispositions
qui sont devant nous je crois que il
restera peut-être un point sur lequel
nous devons discuter vous savez c'est
l'intervention du juge des libertés dans
le cadre de la rétention pour lequel le
texte du gouvernement me paraissait même
positif en tous les cas apport à une
vraie avancée
certains de nos collègues sont inquiets
je souhaite je vais essayer autant que
faire se peut de les rassurer
même si la commission des lois il est
vrai n'a pas admis à supprimer cet
article
parce que l'amendement donc de gérard
longuet qui souhaitait revenir à la
version initiale du sénat a à nouveau
été rejetée en commission c'est bien ça
alors effectivement en commission il a
été rejetée nous allons arriver en
science publique ne parle pas
aujourd'hui mais probablement demain ou
après demain sur ce sujet là cela va
faire débat il y aura vote
nous ne verrons l'issue je crois que
c'est tout l'intérêt du débat du débat
parlementaire si tout était bloqué
davance fixé d'avant ce serait pas tout
à fait complètement intéressant là il ya
un enjeu de conviction il faut expliquer
et donc c'est sur quoi je vais
m'astreindre dans les heures qui
viennent
le gouvernement a également déposé un
amendement qui prévoit que les étrangers
condamnés en france pour terrorisme une
fois leur peine purgée risqueront à
nouveau
dix-huit mois de rétention administratif
les associations s'inquiètent de ce qui
pourrait être un déboire guantanamo à la
française dont on attendait alors il
faut quand même préciser les choses cet
amendement sur le fond vous avez raison
il faut tout de même rappeler qu'en
réalité ce n'est pas dix huit mois d'un
seul coup c'est à plusieurs périodes de
trois ou six mois renouvelé par le juge
des libertés
bien évidemment et le problème c'est
quoi c'est qu'il s'agit que des
personnes condamnées pour terrorisme qui
ont fait l'objet d'un renvoi dans leur
pays d'origine ne se promènent pas dans
la nature indéfiniment c'est ça le sujet
je pense que le sujet est suffisamment
grave et suffisamment important pour ne
pas polémiquer là dessus d'autant plus
que je tiens à leur dire
le juge des libertés est amené à se
prononcer à plusieurs reprises sur leur
maintien en rétention
vous l'avez dit la discussion en
commission mixte paritaire s'annonce
vive à ce que vous pensez que c'est la
version votée par le sénat qui
l'emportera on l'écouté jeu je ne sais
pas ce que je sais c'est que nous sommes
pour le coup dans un processus
parlementaire qui n'est pas dans
l'urgence donc l'assemblée nationale à
la sortie du texte en revers altex y
reviendra ici et la cmp ne viendra
qu'après donc nous avons encore du temps
pour travailler avancer et faire que les
objectifs poursuivis sont remplies
merci françois noël buffet d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je vous laisse
regagné l'hémicycle du sénat
je vais accueillir maintenant un
sénateur centriste yves détraigne
sénateur du groupe union centriste de la
main de bonjour alors on a vu la semaine
dernière le rôle déterminant des
centristes dans l'adoption de certaines
dispositions de ce projet de loi est ce
qu'il y à une unité du groupe sur
certaines dispositions clés comme par
exemple la procédure actuelle
d'expulsion des sans-papiers la question
de la saisie du juge de la liberté et
des détentions
oui effectivement une unité du groupe
pas le groupe centriste et expriment une
sensibilité humaniste dans l'ensemble de
ces décisions dont la plupart de ces
décisions et sur un texte concernant
l'immigration et bien c'est le moment de
faire sentir la différence du groupe
centriste
justement sur cette procédure de saisine
jld il va y avoir vraiment une unité
également tous les centristes vont voter
pour le maintien de la procédure
actuelle écoutez c'est très simple la
constitution dit que c'est le juge
judiciaire qui est le gardien des
libertés individuelles
donc nous considérons que si on renvoie
à cinq jours l'intervention du jld et
bien ils risquent ils risquent
d'intervenir trop tard donc nous pensons
effectivement qu'il faut maintenir à 48
heures le délai d'intervention du juge
des libertés et de la détention
alors est-ce que vous pensez que les
modifications qui sont actuellement
apportée par le snav vont rendre au
final ce texte acceptable pour les
groupes centristes et écoutez nous
avions trois points sur lesquels nous
étions très attentif
la question de la déchéance de
nationalité donc nous avons obtenu
satisfaction
un deuxième point qui a été examinée cet
après midi qui concernait la carte de
séjour temporaire pour les étrangers
malades le ministre souhaitait qu'on
laisse le temps à la navette d' examiner
plus à fond cette question donc pour
l'instant la ferme
si son cours je vais dire et puis il
reste ce point sur le jld donc si
effectivement nous obtenons satisfaction
sur le jld
et si au terme de la navette la question
des étrangers malades qui sont séjour
temporaire pour se soigner et réglé bien
je pense que le groupe dans à
l'unanimité adoptera cette loi alors
depuis ce matin vous avez un nouveau
président groupe centriste et agissait
de françois zocchetto vous vous
souteniez hervé maurey ce que vous
pensez que ce nouveau président va
permettre de conserver de l'unité du
groupe donc à six mois des sénatoriales
et un an de la présidentielle ce que
vous avez dit ce n'est pas la priorité
effectivement du président quel qu'il
soit bon c'est françois zocchetto il va
très bien et je souhaite bonne chance à
françois zocchetto c'est quelqu'un que
je connais et que j'apprécie la priorité
donc du président du groupe c'est
effectivement de veiller à la réélection
du maximum des sénateurs sortants qui se
représentent du groupe centriste
et si possible d'obtenir de nouveaux
sénateurs centristes alors moi j'avais
proposé plus tôt la candidature d'hervé
maurey pourquoi parce qu'un vent mauvais
n'est pas renouvelable et que la tâche
que va devoir mener le président du
groupe centriste va nécessiter la
possibilité de pouvoir se déplacer quand
on est renouvelable en a évidemment
moins disent militer ceci dit
françois zocchetto est parfaitement
conscient de ça il a pris des
engagements devant le groupe je le fais
tout à fait confiance et aucun doute
pour qu'effectivement ils oeuvrent pour
le maintien d'un groupe important et
plus important si possible qu
actuellement au centre de de l'hémicycle
du sénat
merci yves détraigne d'avoir répondu à
nos questions donc je vous laisse
regagné l'hémicycle poursuivre l'examen
du projet de loi sur l'immigration
je vais accueillir maintenant eliane
assassi sénatrice donc du groupe
communiste bonjour alors tout à l'heure
il ya eu le sénat a rejeté en fait la
restriction du droit au séjour médical
est ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle donc
pour les étrangers en situation
irrégulière atteints de pathologies
graves
bien sûr c'est une très bonne nouvelle
pour est pour eux et pour toutes celles
et ceux qui les accompagnent dans les
moments relativement difficile il faut
bien s'imaginer dans quelles conditions
on arrive en france et on qu'on aurait
pu donc être rejetée de notre pays parce
qu'elle a atteint d'une balle logée
pathologie qui soi-disant seraient
dispensés dans notre pays d'origine mais
dans quelles conditions voilà donc je
crois que c'est une grande victoire pour
à la fois les étrangers concernaient
toutes les associations qui les
soutiennent en revanche vous aviez
déposé un amendement sur les articles 17
a en fait concernant le maintien du
droit au séjour pour certaines personnes
aient voulu vous évoquez notamment le
cas des bulgares et des rangs vous avez
jugé cet article dangereuse peut nous
expliquer pourquoi il est dangereux et
les stigmatisant alors on voit bien que
ce projet de loi et ont quelques pas
quelque part un petit cadeau que l'on
fait à nicolas sarkozy puisqu'on y
inscrire des mesures qu'il avait
annoncées à grenoble donc la dernière
fois est donc particulièrement cette
stigmatisation sur les populations roms
et sur les populations de gare donc
cette stigmatisation est vraiment
extravagantes dangereuse pour les
libertés pour les droits et pour la
liberté de ces personnes mais pas que
parce que ça peut être la porte ouverte
à d'autres mesures concernant d'autres
populations
globalement on a vu que la semaine
dernière les centres et se sont alliés à
l'opposition 2
gauche pour rejeter l'extension de la
déchéance de nationalité comment vous
sentez l'ambiance sur ce texte que le
sénat peut vraiment jouer son rôle de
garant des libertés
je pense qu'il ya quelques petites
quelques petits articles qui pourraient
faire l'objet des débats intéressants
ça peut être le cas sur ce qu on appelle
les zones d'attentes sac à dos ça
pourrait être le cas aussi sur le
bannissement
voilà donc je pense que ce sont encore
où les mariages aussi puisqu'on n'a pas
témoigné avec les maillages soi-disant
hongrie donc on peut avoir des débats
intéressants et j'espère en tout cas
qu'il pourrait y avoir des bouger au
sein même de ce qui est aujourd'hui la
majorité au sénat en tout cas moi j'ai
confiance et est ce que je j'ai apprécié
c'est qu'il y ait un vrai débat d'idées
un vrai débat de fond et que dès lors
que des parlementaires semble que les
droits et libertés des personnes sont
attaquées
il ya une relative mobilisation cela dit
il faut rester vigilant rien n'est gagné
d'avancé
vous évoquez effectivement la question
des mariages rives en être question dans
quelques instants dans l'hémicycle vous
vous parlez d'une escroquerie au
sentiment qu'est ce que ça veut dire et
pas d'une escroquerie parce qu'on parle
du principe que un des deux ne serait
pas vraiment amoureux c'est ce qu'on
appelle et malgré à la différence des
mariages blancs donc c'est de toute
façon une escroquerie aux sentiments
voilà moi je l'appelle comme ça c'est
une escroquerie aux sentiments des gens
et ça aussi c'est inadmissible cette
question du mariage risque qu'est ce que
vous attendez des sénateurs j'espère
qu'il va y avoir un bouger notamment de
la part des centristes qui sont un petit
peu partage effectivement sur sûr sur
cette question qui là encore touche aux
droits et aux libertés individuelles
donc voilà on va se battre dans
l'hémicycle et puis on espère que tout
ceci va dépasser les simples rangs de
l'opposition
merci eliane assassi doit répondu à nos
questions donc je vous laisse regagné
l'hémicycle du sénat
je vais accueillir maintenant jacques
mézard sénateurs du groupe erds au
sénateur du cantal
bonjour alors vous allez
bientôt retourner dans l'hémicycle pour
aborder la question des mariages gris
alors vous pour vous c'est une notion
subjective qu'est ce que ça veut dire
quoi le mariage prix très simplement
c'est par exemple un français qui est
amoureux et qui épouse
par exemple une une femme qui l'aurait
dissimulé qu'elle ne l'aiment pas et
qu'elle l'épousé simplement pour entrer
sur le territoire français c'est une
notion qui est extrêmement vague
d'ailleurs le rapport de la commission
le dis très clairement et le texte
prévoit qu'il y ait une sanction de cinq
ans de prison et 15000 euros d'amande
en fait c'est surtout un affichage parce
que la répression du mariage blanc c'est
à dire de la dissimulation volontaire de
ce mariage pour des raisons qui sont des
raisons de de nationalité existe déjà
dans le code et il y a très peu de cas
qu'ils sont poursuivis en moyenne une
quarantaine par an donc arriver à faire
la preuve que l'un dissimulé que l'autre
est amoureux je souhaite bon courage aux
juridictions françaises si vraiment ce
texte passe tel qu'il est quand on n'a
pas prouvé dès sa bonne foi c'est toute
la difficulté de l'exercice c'est là où
on démontre que c'est vraiment une
volonté d'affichage médiatique mais que
cela n'a aucun sens au niveau du concret
la vie de tous les jours une
stigmatisation selon vous au des
étrangers en fait on se marie uniquement
quand on est étranger pour obtenir la
nationalité française c'est fin c'est en
tout cas l'image que l'on veut montrer
qui ne correspond pas à la réalité
sauf évidemment dans quelques cas qui
sont tout à fait possibles à identifier
l'annulation la nullité du mariage est
toujours possible le parquet peut la
solliciter
dans un délai de cinq ans mais on voit
bien que les cas concrets de poursuites
à ce niveau là sont extrêmement rares et
que sur ce dossier
il y aura très peu de cas concrets qui
seront poursuivis devant les tribunaux
parce que c'est pratiquement impossible
à démontrer
une dernière question jacques mézard en
tant qu'avocat il ya eu des rappels au
règlement
donc plusieurs sénateurs ont exprimé
leur soutien à la fronde des magistrats
est ce que vous comprenez la colère des
magistrats après les propos nicolas
sarkozy dans l'affairé des siens oui
parce que ce n'est pas la première fois
que l'on constate une une méfiance tout
à fait évidente vis-à-vis des magistrats
on l'a vu récemment sur la loppsi avec
le problème des peines plancher avec la
rétention de sûreté
on a l'impression que le gouvernement ne
fait pas confiance aux magistrats
c'est aussi tout à fait le cas avec le
projet qui va vraisemblablement arriver
d'arrivée de jurés populaires dans les
tribunaux correctionnels
or les magistrats le vivent très mal
parce que contrairement à ce qui est
indiqué en france les juridictions
pénales sont assez répressive par
rapport à ce qui existe ailleurs en
europe
les magistrats ont beaucoup de travail
et ils ont l'impression le sentiment
justifié d'être déconsidéré par
des propos qui sont tenus par en
particulier celui qui est le garant de
l'indépendance de la magistrature en
france
merci jacques mézard tout de suite donc
nous prenons la direction de l'hémicycle
poursuivre la question des mariages gris
merci de votre fidélité et à bientôt sur
public sénat du code de l'entrée et du
séjour des étrangers et du droit d'asile
leur sort des ressortissants étrangers
qui séjournent régulièrement en france
depuis au moins 18 mois peut demander à
bénéficier de son droit à être rejoint
au titre du regroupement familial par
son conjoint
si ce dernier est âgé d'au moins 18 ans
et les enfants du couple mineurs de 18
ans en application de l'article l 411
points 4 l'enfant éligibles cette
procédure s'entend comme celui ayant une
filiation légalement établie y compris
fond adoptées en vertu d'une décision
d'adoption sous réserve de la
vérification par le ministère public de
la régularité de cette décision
lorsqu'elle a été prononcée à l'étranger
si ces conditions exclu a priori de ce
dispositif les enfants recueillis par
décision légale une dérogation est
prévue au bénéfice des seuls enfants
algériens en application de l'accord
franco-algérien du 27 décembre 1968 pour
les enfants qui sont nés ailleurs
l'autorité consulaire apprécient
souverainement au cas par cas
la délivrance d'un visa de long séjour
outre les refus de visa qui demeurent
fréquents et peuvent favoriser l'entrée
illégale de ces enfants en france
cette situation a des répercussions sur
les droits sociaux des intéressés qui ne
peuvent prétendre aux prestations
familiales
l'octroi de ces prestations pour les
enfants étrangers suppose en effet que
ces derniers soient entrés régulièrement
en france par la procédure du
regroupement familial conditions
impossibles à remplir pour les enfants
sous kafala autres qu'algérien comme
l'impliquent la jurisprudence du conseil
d'état et du cdh
il apparaît nécessaire de modifier le
céser d'un afin de prévoir que les
enfants régulièrement recueillies en
france selon une décision de recueil
légal sont éligibles à la procédure du
regroupement familial
pour toutes ces raisons je vous propose
d'adopter le présent amendement
merci quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
même le président monsieur le ministre
sur cet amendement 335 bon je rappelle
effectivement qu'il vise à créer un
droit au regroupement familial pour les
enfants mineurs régulièrement recueillis
notamment par un étranger établi en
france sur tout en reconnaissant que la
procédure de regroupement familial ne
peut en principe bénéficier qu'aux
enfants de l'intéressé la juridiction
administrative impose d'administration
d' en étendre le bénéfice au cas par cas
aux enfants n'appartenant pas à cette
catégorie si le refus de
l'administration et ses petites de
porter atteinte une atteinte pardon
disproportionnée au droit de l'intéressé
à mener une vie familiale normale ou
d'être contraires à l'intérêt supérieur
de l'enfant
il semble donc que cet amendement 335
soit largement satisfaits par ledroit
vig en vigueur sans qu'il soit
nécessaire de créer une catégorie
spécifique
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
commission des lois a émis un avis
défavorable
l'avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre donc l'opportunité du
regroupement familial
est appréciée au regard de l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant c'est ça qui
naturellement et qui doit compter et de
ce fait derrière le conseil d'état a
rappelé que l'intérêt de l'enfant jules
site est en principe de vivre auprès de
la personne qui en vertu d'une décision
de justice qui produisent des effets
juridiques en france et titulaire à son
égard de l'autorité parentale
il s'agit pas donc ceci jean fassions
décline il s'agit donc pas et d'une
procédure d'adoption et il ne s'agit pas
d'un cas d'ouverture comment
regroupement familial même s'il préfet
d'ailleurs peut accorder celui-ci dans
ce cas mais enfin tout cas pour les deux
premières raisons donc avis défavorable
bien s'il n'a pas de filiation de vote
se mettre aux voix cet amendement qui a
été présentée par monsieur gautier ceux
qui sont favorables son adoption
ceux qui sont contre
il n'est pas adoptée après l'article 21
que j'en article additionnel de 336 que
présente monsieur antoine est cet
amendement offre au calendrier
législatif des parlements l'occasion de
montrer que les deux assemblées sont
complémentaires
l'assemblée nationale vient en effet
d'adopter à l'unanimité les dispositions
une proposition de loi luttons contre
l'habitat indigne en outre-mer le
problème du logement est
particulièrement grave en outre mer
entre l'essor démographique et
l'immigration clandestine chiffres de
l'habitat insalubre ne sont pas l'objet
de la discussion
mais apporte un éclairage particulier à
cet amendement
en guyane à titre d'exemple ans pour
cent des logements n'ont pas
d'électricité 14% pas l'eau courante et
40 pensons seulement sont reliés à tout
à l'égout 20 % du patrimoine bâti peut
être considéré comme un habitat
insalubre et indigne jeu pour vous poser
un exemple que l'actualité du brésil
rend particulièrement grave en effet
dans un quartier de cayenne située sur
le flanc ouest du mont baduel 200
familles sont logées dans des
habitations de fortune sur des parcelles
dans le trm menace de ces boules et si
l'ampleur de cette situation est
intolérable en outre mer elle ne l'est
pas moins en métropole la politique de
la ville se doit de résorber avec les
moyens qu'on à leur disposition à la
commune le département et la région des
habitations insalubres en ont le constat
que font les acteurs locaux lors de la
mise en place de ces opérations de
restructuration et de rénovation urbaine
et qu'une partie de la population
occupant ces logements indignes et en
situation irrégulière procédé alors une
politique de résorption de l'habitat
insalubre revient à traiter un problème
de taille celui de la situation de
grenoble de personnes sans papiers
installés parfois depuis des années
or puisqu'il n'est pas possible de
reloger ces personnes l'absence de titre
régulier serbie stack à l'attribution
d'un logement social même provisoire
il faut soit régulée régulariser ces
personnes soient les expulser devant les
troubles à l'ordre public
également à l'ordre économique que cette
confrontation peut générer les acteurs
publics renonce bien souvent à mettre en
oeuvre leurs opérations d'urbanisme
ce qui laisse perdurer une situation
insoutenable à nos tracts alternative
qui a pratiqué est aussi intenable
l'opération de restructuration urbaine
se fait avec les services de
l'immigration de la préfecture qui
s'engagent à traiter les dossiers le
plus rapidement possible avec souplesse
en ce qui concerne les conditions de
ressources afin de pouvoir reloger ses
habitants dotée d'un nouveau type de
séjour valide est une c'est les autres
pour permettre aux collectivités
d'assurer leur politique de résorption
de l'habitat insalubre
sans trop craindre pour notre public je
propose avec cet amendement de supprimer
la condition de ressources pour
l'obtention d'un titre de séjour pour
les habitants de ces zones de
réhabilitation urbaine
merci l'avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
oui même le président sur cet amendement
336 la commission a émis un avis
défavorable
je rappelle que cet amendement propos
d'exempter de la condition de ressources
et de la condition de détention d'une
assurance maladie certains étrangers qui
sollicitent un titre de séjour et qui
réside dans une zone d'habitation
insalubre faisant l'objet d'une
opération de restauration urbaine deux
observations sur cet amendement
tout d'abord que son dispositif vise
uniquement les titulaires d'une carte de
résident de longue durée communauté
européenne délivré par un autre état
membre de l'union européenne ainsi que
les membres de leur famille ce qui
paraît particulièrement restrictif
deuxième observation sur le fond cet
amendement présente l'inconvénient
d'introduire évidemment me semble-t-il
une discrimination entre les étrangers
résidant dans une zone d'habitation
visée par une opération de restauration
urbaine immobilière pardon et les autres
évident dans ces conditions-là la
commission a émis un avis défavorable
gouvernement monsieur le ministre le
chien antoinette je comprend l'objectif
de votre proposition mais très
concrètement cela aboutirait
à créer une sorte de prime à la
clandestinité alors ça peut peut-être
faire plaisir madame boumediene thiery
je sais pas mais mes respects c'est pas
l'objectif du texte donc c'est pour ça
même si encore une fois je comprends
l'objectif que j'émets un avis
défavorable
merci pas de monsieur antoine est
monsieur le ministre
dans le cas de la déclaration nous est
proposé d'être des praticiens or là
c'est un amendement qui propose
effectivement d'apporter des réponses
pragmatiques par rapport à des
situations que tous les maires on compte
quand il s'agit donc de faire de la
résorption de l'habitat insalubre nous
savons très bien que il y à des familles
qui sont en situation régulière qui ne
peuvent pas être relogés et dans les
faits dans les faits les services
n'arrive pas à expulser ces personnes
donc ce sont des personnes qui restent
toujours sur le territoire de la commune
qui reste sur je dirais entre guillemets
le compte des collectivités locales
que faisons-nous d'allant de l'ordre
dans ses comptes dans ces cas pratiques
merci pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote je mets aux voix
cet amendement qui a été présentée par
monsieur antoinette ceux qui sont
favorables à son adoption
ceux qui sont contre n'est pas adopté
mais passons à l'article 21 bis avec un
amendement le 150 que présente madame
gauthier morin merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous jugeons cet article
inadmissible et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous proposons cet amendement
de suppression
cet article durci en effet les
conditions d'obtention d'une carte dorée
de résident en effet une fois de plus
porter le soupçon sur les mariages
mixtes envisagé uniquement sous l'angle
de la fraude pour acquérir la
nationalité française
comme si cette pratique était généralisé
et constituer un véritable fléau pour la
société française
depuis 2003 la majorité n'hésitent
d'ailleurs pas à stigmatiser ces
mariages des textes qui nous ont été
présentés successivement et celui ci
n'échappe pas à la règle
soupçonne l'étranger de perpétuellement
enfreindre les lois
ainsi cet article exclut les années de
mariage de la durée de résistants de
résidence requises pour l'attribution de
la carte de résident cela ne nous semble
pas justifiée ni adapté eu égard au
faible nombre de condamnations pour
fraude qui rappelons le sont par
ailleurs pénalement sanctionné cette
sanction pénale amende et prison semble
suffisante au regard de l'enjeu et ne
nous paraît pas opportun de créer une
notion juridique de nos résidences sur
le sol français
dans ces cas là merci l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur un
avis défavorable
cet article 21 bis qui a été introduit
d'ailleurs par nos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale vise à exclure
expressément les années pendant
lesquelles un étranger a vécu en
situation régulière grâce à un mariage
frauduleux de la durée de résidence
requises pour l'attribution d'une carte
de résident cela vient d'être appelé par
notre collègue mathon poinat il s'agit
là en réalité d'une mesure de cohérence
avec les autres dispositions notre droit
qui vise à prévenir la lutte contre les
mariages de complaisance et la
commission des lois d'ems-chemie un avis
défavorable à vis du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre la présidente
le législateur a décidé de sanctionner
sévèrement les personnes qui contractent
qui organisent des mariages de
complaisance avec le seul objectif en
tout cas l'objectif principal de se voir
délivrer une carte de séjour ou encore
jeudi législateur je vends bien
volontiers acte sans doute pas vous mais
il n'en reste pas moins qu'à un moment
donné le législateur s'est prononcé dans
ce sens là et donc dans la continuité de
cette volonté
l'article 21 10 prévoit effectivement
que les années de résidence acquise
grâce à un titre de séjour titre de
séjour qui ont été obtenues
frauduleusement en détournant
l'institution du mariage
eh bien ça ne doit pas donner de droit
au séjour ultérieure et donc cette
disposition c'est la conséquence logique
j'allais dire scène de la pénalisation
des mariages de complaisance donc avis
défavorable at il des explications de
vote
je n'en vois pas je mets aux voix cet
amendement 150 ceux qui sont favorables
à son adoption
ceux qui sont contre il n'est pas adopté
je fait voter sur l'article 20 bis ceux
qui sont pour l'adoption de l'article 20
bis 21 bis qui sont contre l'article 21
10 et adopter un autre article
additionnel après l'article 21 10 le 345
rectifier que présente monsieur anziani
oui madame la présente chemise pêcheurs
collègues la directive 2309 après objets
d'harmoniser les conditions
d'acquisition du statut de résident de
longue durée
cette directive pose un certain nombre
de règles pour les états européens et
nous savons une des règles c'est que des
états peuvent évidemment appliquer des
dispositions plus favorables mais ne
peuvent en aucun cas avoir une
législation plus restrictive et donc on
ne peut pas ajouter conditions qui ne
sont pas prévues par la directive
pourtant dans ce texte
nous voyons sur trois points ce texte
est plus dur que le texte la directive
le premier point c'est l'acquisition du
statut de résident de longue durée dans
un état membre la directive sur ce point
est très claire
son article cas précise des états
membres accorde le statut de résident de
longue durée ressortissants de pays
tiers et c'est donc c'est bien à cordes
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs votre
prédécesseur monsieur me l'intérieur
nous a fait une leçon de conjugaison
pour nous dire que lorsque le verbe et à
ce temps alors il n'y a pas besoin
d'impératifs et que ça va de soi que
accorde ça veut dire de droit et bien
pourtant si on regarde le texte que vous
nous présentez et l'article 314 8
exactement on voit que ce verbe accordé
perd son sens et qu'il n'y a pas
d'acquisition de plein droit mais qui a
un pouvoir discrétionnaire du préfet
donc il ya là une première non
conformité à la directive deuxième non
conformité la directive prévoit
l'obligation de juste que je
l'obligation de justifier de sa volonté
s'établir durablement en france n'est
pas une condition nécessaire et elle
pose en fait que lorsqu'une personne a
résidé régulièrement dans un état membre
pendant cinq années consécutives
eh bien les ya là la preuve de son
ancrage de la personne dans le pays et
donc c'est une preuve qui est suffisante
et bien là encore le test vous nous
proposez n'est pas conforme à ce texte
de la directive troisième point la
directive précise qu'il y a un caractère
suffisant des ressources
au regard des conditions de logement et
que ce caractère suffisant ne doit pas
être plus durement explicité que qu'elle
ne le fait elle même est bien là vous
avez dans votre texte
une condition plus importante puisqu'il
ya nécessité de l'avis du maire et donc
pour toutes ces raisons et bien il nous
semble que sur ces trois points au moins
bien sûr le test vous nous présentez
n'est pas conforme à la directive et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous vous
proposons cet amendement qui rétablit
tout le sens de la directive européenne
merci quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur donc cet
amendement 345 rectifié donc je rappelle
qu' effectivement et propose de modifier
les conditions d'attribution de là carte
de résident afin selon les auteurs de
mettre notre droit en conformité avec le
droit communautaire
moi je voudrais rappeler que les
conditions prévues par le
le droit national pour l'obtention d'une
carte de résident paraît sûre du point
de vue de la commission tous les cas
conforme à la directive du 25 novembre
l'article 5 de la directive prévoit en
effet que les états membres exigent du
ressortissant d'un pays tiers de fournir
la preuve qu'il dispose pour lui et pour
les membres de sa famille qui chante à
sa charge un de ressources stables
régulière et suffisante pour subvenir à
ses propres besoins et à ceux des
membres de sa famille sans recourir au
système d aide sociale de l'état membre
concerné de d'une assurance maladie pour
tous les risques normalement couverts
pour leurs propres ressortissants dans
l'état membre concerné par ailleurs les
états membres le site peuvent exiger que
les ressortissants de pays tiers
satisfasse à des conditions
d'intégration conformément à leur droit
national peut donc parfaitement
considérer que l'examen des conditions
d'activité professionnelle de logement
est actuellement prévue par nos textes
en vigueur constituent une déclinaison
de ces dispositions et la commission des
lois dont il vit un avis défavorable
ministre à l'avis du gouvernement pas de
demandes d'explications de vote mais aux
voix l'amendement 345 rectifier quels
sont ceux qui sont favorables à son
adoption
ceux qui sont contre
n'est pas adoptée après l'article 21 vis
un autre article additionnel avec un
amendement 487 que présente mme alain
bouvet yens thierry monsieur le ministre
avec mon amendement je pense que je ne
vais pas non plus vous faire plaisir
mais je crois que nous ne sommes pas là
pour ça n'est ce pas alors mon
amendement va aller dans le sens des
recommandations et des doléances qui
sont faites à ce sujet par le conseil
national de l'ordre des médecins qui
demandent que les actes médicaux
réalisés non dans l'intérêt
thérapeutique du patient mais dans le
cadre des politiques d'immigration soit
bannie en particulier les radiologies
osseuse
cette demande de l'ordre des médecins
émane de la déclaration européenne des
professionnels de santé pour un accès
aux soins de santé sans discrimination
elle fait suite au comité consultatif
national d'éthique sur les méthodes de
détermination de l'âge à des fins
juridique du 23 juin 2005 au rapport de
l'académie nationale de médecine du 22
janvier 2007 et aux différentes
recommandations de la défenseure des
enfants
il est donc nécessaire d'interdire ces
pratiques pour déterminer l'âge d'un
étranger dont la minorité est remise en
cause par l'administration et de lui
permettre de justifier par tout moyen de
son âge en cas de doute sur la véracité
des états civils que pourrait fournir
l'intéressé l'administration pourra
notamment faire application des alinéas
2 et suivants de l'article 45 du code
civil et saisir le procureur de la
république de nantes afin qu'il soit
procédé à la vérification de l'empt
l'authenticité des actes
merci monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de
la commission
l'avis de la commission
est défavorable le biais d'amendements
on l'a compris d'interdire le recours
aux examens osseux
en l'état actuel c'est le seul moyen
disponible pour tenter de déterminer
l'âge d'un mineur notamment et en
particulier si un étranger qui se
prétend mineurs l'est bien évidemment
les documents d'origine d'état civil
étant souvent soit absent ce soit
parfois même douteux quant à leur
garantie d'authenticité
voilà ce qu'on peut dire est qu en
l'état des choses et de la situation on
n'a pas d'autres éléments au d'autres
moyens de pouvoir faire beaucoup mieux
que l'existant sauf à ce que les doses
information qui ne soit donnée la
commission a émis un avis défavorable
ministre à l'avis du gouvernement en
fait ce que je vois plus la banque
la boit je vous propose est en fait
c'est d'interdire si j'ai bien compris
le recours aux méthodes médico légales
pour déterminer l'âge d'un étranger qui
s'affirme être mineure sa lite est
concrètement ce dispositif quand je vous
le rappelle est encadré il est encadré
très précisément il ya de nombreuses
garanties d'abord ça peut être utilisé
que sur décision du procureur
deuxièmement cette méthode n'est utilisé
que dans le cas où il existe un doute
sérieux sur l'état civil de l'étranger
et en était aussi très bien contre 16 et
18 ans est très difficile et terminé
qu'est majeurs et mineurs et en cas de
doute
l'étranger est considéré comme mineur et
bénéficient de tous les droits toutes
les protections qui sont attachés au
statut de mineur alors
je pense qu'il ya une ambiguïté en tout
cas peut-être une information et que
vous n'avez pas rappelé c'est inné
recouru aux tests osseux qu'en zones
d'attentes et centres de rétention c'est
pas un recours général ce sont des
recours très précis très ciblées et par
exemple si votre votre inquiétude
c'était mais je crois pas que ce soit
celle là mais enfin en tout cas plus
largement mais si votre inquiétude c'est
est-ce que ça s'applique à tous les
cadres regroupement familial et ce n'est
pas le cas donc on y recourt on y
recourt que dans les cas que j'ai
indiquées précédemment
donc ça me semble à la fois équilibrée
juste efficace et dans un certain nombre
de cas particulièrement protecteur au
contraire donc c'est pour ça qu'on émet
un avis défavorable
si monsieur le ministre une palette
madame eu beau me yann gré
je voudrais rappeler à monsieur le
ministre que cette demande nous vient de
l'ordre des médecins et qu'elle fait
partie d'une déclaration européenne des
professionnels de santé
d'accord que d'autre part les critères
qui sont utilisés aujourd'hui sont très
ancien qui date et qui sont vraiment
plus du tout je veux dire en conformes à
la réalité
par ailleurs concernant la véracité des
actes d'état civil c'est quand même
dommage que il y ait toujours une
suspicion une suspicion permanente et si
vraiment cette suspicion existe alors
pourquoi ne pas tout simplement d un
autre comment dire un autre
administration de permettre la
vérification de cet état civil
merci pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote je mets aux voix
à l'amendement 487 ceux qui sont
favorables à son adoption ou de revient
à l'exprimer en levant la main
contre n'est pas adoptée nous passons à
l'article 21 terre avec trois
amendements identiques qui sont des
amendements de suppression
l'amendement numéro 39 rectifier que
présente monsieur mézard
merci madame le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet article
21 terre n'est pas une création du
gouvernement mais a été inséré dans le
texte à la demande des députés de
l'assemblée nationale
c'est une incongruité juridique cet
article 21 terre
l'invention du mariage gris je rappelle
que le mariage gris il y en a un qui est
amoureux et pas l'autre
et forcément celui qui est amoureux et
le français est donc celui qui n'est pas
amoureux et l'étranger j'ai résumé
mais c'est exactement la réalité et ce
merveilleux texte introduit par les
députés veut appliquer aux mariages dits
gris mais nous sommes vraiment dans la
grisaille juridique les peines qui sont
appliquées par l'article l 622 3-1 au
mariage de complaisance en moyenne ya
une quarantaine de condamnation par an
en disant que ses peines
c'est à dire cinq ans d'emprisonnement
et 15000 euros damende par rapport à la
proposition de la commission parce que
les députés étaient allés jusqu'à 7 en 1
qui autant le faire largement et bien
cet article dit ses peines oui justement
quand on aime on ne compte pas il mais
quand on n'aime pas on devrait en tenir
compte aussi
ces peines sont également encourus
lorsque l'étranger qui a contracté
mariage à dissimuler ses intentions à
son conjoint à leur haut niveau de
l'infraction pénale la félicitation il
fallait y penser parce que celui qui
arrivera à prouver la dissimulation des
intentions je lui souhaite bonne chance
au niveau de la jurisprudence et
d'ailleurs je ne suis pas le seul
le président du prg puisque à la page
122 et à la page 123 du rapport le
rapporteur expriment des doutes et des
réserves extrêmement importante par
rapport à cet article qui n'a aucun sens
au niveau de l'application concrète et
avec des arguments tout à fait pertinent
monsieur le rapporteur
puisque vous dites que votre commission
observe que les mariages gris sont
d'ores et déjà inclus dans le champ de
l'infraction de mariages frauduleux
réprimé par l'article l 622 1 du code
des étrangers c'est vous qui le dites
donc si c'est déjà inscrit dans le code
et dans l'article 623 qu'est ce que
c'est que ce mariage gris ça n'a aucun
sens et vous essayer d'atténuer le choc
en ramenant au niveau de l'échelle des
peines la proposition de sanction à 5
ans qui était l'ancien l'article
existants et en indiquant mais je pense
que vous conviendrez avec moi monsieur
le rapporteur que c'est quand même
limite que on modifie ce qui est issu de
l'assemblée nationale par la
dissimulation des intentions je crois
vraiment que on aurait pu se passer de
cet article 21 terre qui ne changera
strictement rien à la réalité par
rapport aux poursuites qui peuvent
exister aujourd'hui sur les mariages de
complaisance et qui n'a même pas un
effet d'affichage pas ce que c'est
j'allais dire que c'est triste de
ramener l'amour des français à
des sanctions de cette nature alors que
ça n'a vraiment aucun sens l'amendement
151 qui le défend madame mathon poinat
oui merci madame la présidente
alors c'est vrai que cet article 20
tiers et et dangereux dangereux parce
qu'il porte en lui en fait une
conception suspicieuse de l'étranger et
anvers également les mariages mixtes
il veut en effet réprimer les mariages
du gris ou le conjoint français ont été
abusés par son conjoint étranger
et comme l'a si bien relevé mon collègue
monsieur mézard c'est bien le conjoint
étranger qui qui serait le fauteur de
troubles donc il crée cet article un
délit d'escroquerie aux sentiments qui
ne présente pas les caractéristiques de
sécurité juridique suffisante
comment apporter la preuve de
l'escroquerie aux sentiments et commet
également prouver la bonne foi du
conjoint français il nous paraît
particulièrement dangereux d'introduire
dans la loi des dispositions aussi floue
et aussi subjective mais elles ont pour
seule conséquence d'accroître
l'insécurité la précarité de statut dans
laquelle se trouvent les couples mixtes
et particulièrement le conjoint étranger
de plus cette mesure est plus que
superflu l'arsenal juridique est
largement pourvu en matière de lutte
contre les mariages blancs
la multitude de réformes relatives à
l'immigration engagé d'ailleurs depuis
2003 est obnubilée par le mariage de
complaisance n'est ce pas suffisant
ce sont pléthore de mesures
inadmissibles qui ont été adoptées les
instruments de lutte contre les mariages
blancs existe les sanctions pénales
également n'exclut aucunement des
mariages gris qui peuvent être frappés
de nullité et se voit sanctionné par le
retrait ou le refus de renouvellement de
carte de séjour voire par une décision
d'éloignement
donc ce dispositif tend à faire croire
que cette situation échapperait à la loi
ce qui est loin d'être le cas
il n'y a donc aucune raison de l'évoquer
de manière particulière ni d'aggraver
les sanctions
applicable bon je crois que cet article
est à rejeter en votant notre amendement
pour que cette surenchère sur les
mariages de complaisance cesse enfin le
337 madame boumédiene thiery
oui cet amendement vise à supprimer
l'article 21 terre relatif à
l'augmentation des peines pénales
encourues par un étranger accusé de
mariages de complaisance avec tromperie
volontaire ce que vous avez appelé donc
le mariage gris cet article nauséabond
stigmatise les mariages mixtes et
introduit une nouvelle suspicion celle
de fraude aux sentiments qui pèse
uniquement sur la personne de l'étranger
évidemment cette disposition est donc
contraire à l'article 1er de la
constitution qui assure l'égalité de
tous devant la loi
les français étant selon la rédaction de
cet article 21 terre exempte de tout
soupçon par ailleurs en pratique cette
mesure qui présuppose qu'il soit statué
sur la nature et l'intensité des
sentiments d'un conjoint est évidemment
inapplicable sauf à conduire à
l'arbitraire sur quels éléments se
fonder in concreto pour déterminer qu
untel ou unetelle a pu peindre des
sentiments en vue de conclure une union
maritale et donc selon la philosophie de
cet article dans le seul but d'obtenir
un titre de séjour ou encore la noce des
françaises enfin permettez moi monsieur
me disent de vous rappeler qu en droit
civil de la famille le dol
c'est à dire les manoeuvres mensongère
ayant été déterminante du consentement
n'est pas une cause d'annulation du
mariage
en effet ce principe étant repris par
antoine loisel considéré comme le
premier penseur du droit français dans
une formule devenue adage du droit civil
français en mariage trompe qui peuvent
en d'autres termes concernant le droit
pénal français pourrait qu'elle
sanctionné en l'appliquant de surcroît
uniquement au conjoint de nationalité
étrangère ce qui est depuis des siècles
rejetée par des principes fondateurs du
droit civil de la famille il en va
différemment lorsque les deux époux
s'accordent à conclure un mariage de
complaisance
celui que l'on appelle mariage blanc
mais qui est déjà sanctionné par le code
pénal
ainsi que par le code civil sous l'angle
du défaut de consentement entraînant la
nullité de mariage
il est donc inutile de prévoir d'autres
sanctions cet amendement de suppression
doit donc d'a4 être adopté l'article 21
terre étant à la fois en effet
discriminant envers les conjoints de la
société étrangère de plus inutile et
inapplicable
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur imams la présidence sur ces
trois amendements la commission a émis
un avis défavorable parce qu'ils
sollicitent et demande la suppression
pure et simple de l'article prévue par
ce texte
pour autant je voudrais préciser que la
commission des lois a revu complètement
la rédaction de cet article pour tenir
compte notamment des observations que
vous avez relevé tout à l'heure la
première a été d'intégrer la notion de
mariage gris dans la législation
applicable aujourd'hui donc
donc ya pas de difficulté me semble-t-il
sur ce point est par ailleurs en
reprenant la sanction pénales encourues
pour la maintenir ou la con dans l'état
du droit positif donc
et ceci sur la base d'un amendement que
j'avais déposé et qui a été approuvé par
la commission des lois
je voudrais peut-être vous rappeler
simplement la rédaction un cadet proposé
c'est celle relative je cite ces peines
sont également encourus lorsque
l'étranger qui a contacté mariage à
dissimuler ses intentions à son conjoint
alors que par cette rédaction
on a à la fois préciser les conditions
dans lesquelles le mariage était
intervenue et en même temps maintenue au
niveau de celle des peines voilà la
raison pour laquelle l'avis est
défavorable
merci monsieur ministre l'avis du
gouvernement la présidente même avis que
que la commission bon il s'agit tout
simplement aujourd'hui de reconnaître
qu'il existe une différence fondamentale
entre le mariage blanc et le mariage
avec tromperie sur les sentiments dans
le premier cas les deux époux sont
complices naturellement alors que dans
le second il y à une victime et ses
différences elle doit se traduire dans
notre droit pénal
j'aurais simplement au site et une
lettre qui est parvenu dès hier à mon
prédécesseur qui est parvenu à eric
besson aujourd'hui je vous lis pas tout
la lettre et je l'espère vous auriez un
extrait aujourd'hui je me rends compte
que mon mariage est une mascarade
tout est mensonge je n'arrive plus à
dormir tout défilent dans ma tête
comment j'ai pu être aussi naïve pour
croire en ses sentiments ma famille
m'avait pourtant prévenu mais j'étais
aveugle et je pensait offrir ma
virginité à l'homme de ma vie mais s'il
est avéré un monstre de la pile côté 6
si ça vous fait sourire c'est votre
droit jouer c'est une laque est parvenu
joueurs qu'on tient à votre disposition
mais il s'est avéré un monstre de la
pire espèce je me suis fait avoir il
nage il ne m'a jamais aimé tout était
manqué dès le départ
son seul but était d'avoir ses papiers
français je me sens détruit de violer je
constate que s'en amuse certains sur ses
bancs moi pas du tout très honnêtement
j'ai pas des pas du tout le même
sentiment
je considère que c'est un témoignage
particulièrement d'abord émouvant est
particulièrement vrai et qu'on ne peut
pas faire comme si ça n'existait pas et
je suis étonné devant un certain nombre
de femmes sur ses bancs en face de moi
qui ont choqué
avant de s'il vous plaît avant de mettre
aux voix c'est c'est i read amendement
de suppression ben tasca vouliez dire un
mot si madame la présidente je voudrais
en effet faire une explication de vote
tout d'abord je voudrais revenir sur ce
qu'on dit mes collègues en ce qui
concerne la mesure de la sincérité
c'est jacques mézard qui a le premier
soulevé cette question
nous sommes vraiment là au royaume de
l'absurde et quelles que soient les
explications qui nous sont donnés par le
rapporteur et par lé ministre je vous
pose la question quelles pourraient être
les instruments de mesure de la
sincérité et de la tromperie
peut-être faudrait-il vous inspirer pour
arriver à des critères concrets de
l'exemple des tadjik qui inquiète de
voir les étrangers venir est posée
épouse et leur fille ont viennent
d'adopter une loi très concrète qui
impose aux prétendants étrangers
tout d'abord d'acheter un appartement
pour la jeune fille qu'il convoite et
ensuite de résider sur le sol tadjik
pendant au moins un an avant de lui
passer la bague au doigt ça au moins le
mérite d'être tangible je dirais même en
espèces sonnantes et trébuchantes et de
ne pas dépendre de l'arbitraire et de
l'intrusion dans dans la vie intime
en résumé cet article 21 terre est
scandaleusement discriminant à l'égard
des étrangers
il crée un obstacle nouveau aux mariages
mixtes et à l'établissement d'une vie
familiale qui est pourtant une liberté
fondamentale
j'ajoute que ce texte est absolument
disproportionné avec la réalité du
phénomène des mariages mixtes
quand on sait qu'en 2004 sur 88 1123
mariages mixtes célébrés seul 395
mariages blancs ont été annulées par la
justice soit 0,45 pour cent faut-il
rappeler d'ailleurs que le
renouvellement de la carte de séjour
temporaire
elle lui subordonné au fait que la
communauté de vie n'est pas cessé faute
de preuves d'amour c'est au moins une
garantie de constance avec cette
invention du mariage gris la majorité
une fois de plus distille dans l'opinion
publique ou cherchent à distiller dans
l'opinion publique dont j'espère qu'elle
sera plus clairvoyante que nos
gouvernants une méfiance irraisonnée à
l'égard des étrangers
c'est un poison dangereux monsieur le
ministre pour notre démocratie
c'est pourquoi nous proposons d'adopter
les amendements de suppression
merci madame la présidente monsieur
mézard merci madame le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
une explication de vote courte je crois
vraiment que au delà des positions de
principe légitime des membres de cette
assemblée il ya dans cet article 21
terre quelque chose qui est extrêmement
choquant parce que je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est manifestement inapplicable
et leur monsieur le ministre nous a lu
une lettre extrêmement intéressante
adressée à monsieur besson
mais vous savez dans la pratique dans
les problèmes de séparation de corps de
divorce et d'ailleurs je cite là aussi
le rapporteur plusieurs personnes
entendues par votre rapporteur ont
exprimé la crainte que les dispositions
introduites par les députés ne soit
utilisée comme un moyen de pression ou
de chantage par le ressortissant
français dans le cadre d'une procédure
de séparation conflictuelle parce que
votre lettre monsieur le ministre était
très émouvante et votre indignation nous
a certainement convaincu enfin au moins
saint céré en homos sont peut-être
partiellement convaincu bon mais vous
savez je suis convaincu dans la pratique
pour l'avoir vécu professionnellement
qui a beaucoup plus de séducteur et de
séductrice français qui ont utilisé ce
type de mariage au détriment de
l'étranger
donc vous savez à ce jeu là je crois pas
que quiconque sonore de mesurer le degré
de ce2 sentiment de parler comme vous
l'avez fait dans cette lettre de viol et
cetera je crois vraiment que c'est une
disposition qui n'a pas sa place dans un
dans ce projet de loi et qui est
extrêmement néfaste le terme d'ailleurs
de mariages gris je pense que par
rapport à l'objet du litige
je crois que ça démontre qu'elle était
la volonté de l'auteur de cette
introduction de l'amendement de
l'article devant l'assemblée nationale
donc je persiste et je signe
y at il d'autres demandes d'explications
de vote je n'en vois pas
je mets au voile article l'amendement 39
rectifié qui est favorable à son
adoption
qui est contre
il n'est pas adoptée même vote pour le
151 c'est le un amendement de
suppression même va 337 c'est un
amendement de suppression même vote
donc ils ne sont pas adoptées et je fait
voter sur l'article 21 d'air ceux qui
sont favorables à l'adoption de
l'article 21 terre voudront bien
l'exprimer
ceux qui sont contre il est adopté
après l'article 21 terre un amendement 4
497 qui est présentée par monsieur li fé
lui fait au nom de la commission des
lois
oui il s'agit simplement madame le
président d'intégrer l'article 12 bis
dont le chapitre consacré au titre de
séjour plutôt que celui des zones
d'attentes
si l'avis du gouvernement sur cet
amendement monsieur le ministre je mets
aux voix cet amendement sans 497 qui a
été soutenu par monsieur buffet au nom
de la commission des lois
quels sont ceux qui sont favorables à
son adoption ceux qui sont contre ou
qu'ils s'abstiennent
l'amendement est adopté un article
additionnel après l'article 21 terre le
342 qui le présente monsieur diani comme
la présente l'état à des obligations en
matière de protection de la vie de la
famille ses obligations c'est évidemment
ou de s'abstenir de porter atteinte à la
vie privée à la vie familiale
c'est même d'ailleurs une obligation
aussi qui consiste à mettre en oeuvre
tout ce qui est possible pour assurer
aux citoyens une vie familiale normale
le cdh a traduit cette obligation
également en faveur des étrangers
en tout cas en faveur de certaines
catégories d'étrangers qui disposent
d'un titre de séjour
et on voit bien philosophie tout ça ces
titres de séjour sont soumis à la
présentation d'un visa de long séjour
qui lui n'est pas de droit et voilà bien
la contradiction c'est que d'un côté le
cdh a dit au fond vous avez le droit au
respect de votre vie familiale vous avez
le droit donc à mener cette vie
familiale comme vous le souhaitez mais
en même temps on pose immédiatement une
condition qui est celle du visa et que
visant n'étant pas de droit la deuxième
condition ne permet pas de satisfaire
cette obligation générale de l'état
alors nous proposons d'aller jusqu'au
bout de la logique et donc nous
proposons de mettre tout ça en
conformité et de dire qu' il n'y a plus
besoin y aura plus besoin d'eux ou plus
exactement avec cet amendement nous
proposons de délivrer de plein droit un
visa aux personnes qui sont mentionnés
ou un os 2 ou 3 au caté au 7 de
l'article l 211 2 nuls saisi la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
bien sûr cet amendement 342 donc en
réalité il propose d'instaurer une
délivrance de plein droit d'un visa de
long séjour
lorsqu'il est demandé par certaines
catégories d'étrangers membres de la
famille de ressortissants communautaires
enfin adopté bénéficiait d'une
autorisation d'ogm en familiales ou
autres le droit positif permet déjà une
délivrance de plein droit d'un visa de
long séjour à l'étranger marié un
ressortissant français
par ailleurs convient de préciser que
les dispositions de l'article l 211 tiré
2 du code des étrangers oblige
l'autorité administrative à motiver les
refus de long séjour ont posé un certain
nombre de catégories d'étrangers que
banque de la famille d'un échantillon de
français bénéficiaire de l'autorisation
de regrets familiale hésité avant la
motivation s'effectue notamment et ça
c'est le point qui me paraît essentiel
sous le contrôle du juge administratif
au regard du droit à une vie privée et
familiale il semble donc ces
dispositions paraissent suffisantes et
la commission à lui émis un avis
défavorable
monsieur le ministre mais ma vie pas de
demandes d'explications de vote
je mets au voile amendement 342 qui a
été présentée par monsieur diagne ceux
qui sont favorables à son adoption
ceux qui sont contre n'est pas adopté
maintenant trois amendements à l'article
après l'article 21 heures trois
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 343 que présente
monsieur diani lab la présidente
l'exigence d'un visa de long séjour pour
la délivrance d'une carte de séjour aux
conjoints de français pose nombreuses
difficultés
l'article l 211 2 1 du ceseda prévoit
que les conjoints de français entré
régulièrement en france marie en france
et justifiant de six mois de vie commune
avec leur conjoint en france peuvent
déposer leur demande de visa auprès la
préfecture cette formalité en théorie
est un moyen de se prémunir contre toute
expulsion mais dans les faits la
procédure fonctionne autrement en
particulier lorsque le consulat ne
répond pas à la demande de visa dans le
délai des gars qui lui est imparti et en
absence de réponse à la demande de visa
dans ce délai de deux mois la préfecture
considère qu'il s'agit d'un refus
implicite et puis souvent refusé
d'instruire la demande de titre de
séjour ou notifie un refus de lille
délivrance de titres ce
dysfonctionnement de procédures pénalise
donc les personnes ayant un droit à un
titre de séjour et donc nous attirons
votre attention sur le fait que cette
exigence pour les conjoints de français
déjà présents en france porte une
atteinte disproportionnée au droit à une
vie familiale normale qui est consacré
par la convention européenne des droits
de l'homme et le 295 mythifié bis
monsieur toilettes
l'amendement 295 rectifié biscet ce
qu'il présente mais chiant toilettes
et l'a défendu très bien le 148
rectifier non madame assassi donc avec
cet amendement nous voulons supprimer
l'obligation de produire un visa depuis
trois mois lors de la demande de la
carte de séjour temporaire
lorsque celle ci est effectuée par un
étranger entré régulièrement en france
marié avec un ressortissant français et
qui séjourne ensemble en france depuis
plus de six mois
exigez un visa long séjour n'est pas
sans difficulté il est effectivement
prévu que ces personnes sous les
conditions que nous avons déjà évoqué
peuvent demander un visa auprès de la
préfecture
mais cette procédure fonctionne mal il
ya nous quittant l'hémicycle du sénat si
vous souhaitez revoir cette séance notre
site internet publicsenat.fr à suivre le
journal de 19h présenté ce soir par
michel grossiord merci de votre fidélité
et à très bientôt sur public sénat